I'd like you to have your laptop there
or device with des mots open then you
should have exercise 1210
besides you now trill tens are fairly
short exercises especially when you do
it the way we're about to do it which is
with the aid of some technology so I
want you to have a look at the very
first question and I'm going to show you
how to think about this and interpret it
so it starts off it says graph each pair
of equations and find their point of
intersection okay freeze I have a
question for you
intersection what does that mean someone
had never heard the word intersection
what would you use to describe it well
then what would you say intersection is
where two things cross parts ago that's
perfect right if you're driving along
and you hit an intersection it's where
your road it crosses paths with another
road okay so what we're looking for is
these straight lines that we are getting
from these equations are going to cross
paths with each other they're going to
intersect now you can see I have already
and I invite you to do the same I've
already graphed the first equation in
the first question one a y equals x and
then you can see they have provide you
with a second equation which will give
us a second straight line so go over
into desmos and you can see if you hit
enter you can put a new line in there
and you'll see both at the same time the
second one has an equation y equals what
is it y equals what yeah negative x plus
2
okay now can I get a show of hands who
has this on their screen right now who's
up to speed yeah hands up hands up hands
up about half the class okay thank you
hands down all right now before we
inspect this I just want to pause on
some of the language that we learnt
before okay so have a look at our
equations that you can see here y equals
x y equals negative x plus 2 there were
two words that we looked at last lesson
that was super important we're going to
use them again and again they both start
with a letter see one is called the
coefficient and one is called the
constant very good can you help me work
out let's look at this second one what's
the constant in this second equation the
constant is it's two it's this number
over here right
a bit trickier what's the coefficient in
that same a question that's tricky the
coefficients for a number that's
attached to the X which in this case is
a negative one we don't write the 1
because it kind of doesn't change
anything it's the same size okay
what about the first equation what's the
constant in the first equation it's sort
of Heidi right it's plus zero that's why
we don't write it doesn't change
anything
what's the coefficient in the first one
it's just one it's just hiding there one
times X is just X that's why it's not
written okay now this is what you've got
have a look and closer into your two
graphs here and what we want is that
point where they as william said cross
paths that's the point of intersection
so have a look can you guys read off for
me what's the x coordinate of this point
it's one you can read that and what's
the y coordinate coincidentally it's the
same so go ahead in question one a we
write the coordinates don't forget in a
very particular way to indicate that
it's a point right those two values that
you just gave me the x coordinate is the
first number and the y coordinate is the
second number we separate them with a
comma and we've got those two
parenthesis around to indicate this is a
point okay now I'm going to give you a
second to have a look at 1b there's two
different equations there and I invite
you rather than having like a million
equations here which is gonna be very
confusing just change these two
equations the ones that are there at the
minute they're probably red and blue
like mine go ahead and adjust those two
so that they match the question or
rather the equations in Part B can you
do that and then see if you can find the
point of intersections you are okay so
have a look up has what have you what
you've got on your screen does it match
this so it looks like maybe your red and
your blue are swapped over it doesn't
really matter which ones which okay so
this time again we've got a point of
intersection what is the point of
intersection what are its coordinates 1
comma 2 very good again the first value
is the X which is horizontal there's the
1 which we can see up there and your
second value is the 2 I can here's what
I'd like you to do I'd like you to
finish question 1 again use the
technology every time but what I want
you to last
they do is this is why I asked you to
have rulers I want you to choose one of
the questions ABCDEF I don't mind which
one you choose and I want you to
physically draw that one in your book
you don't have to draw all six you can
use technology for all six but I do want
you to physically draw at least one of
them in question one into your book show
the two lines show the point of
intersection I'll let you choose which
one you want okay when we have a look at
questions two and three I don't want you
to just march through I want you to
think about it in a particular way so
look at it with me it says question two
what's the point of intersection and
then they provide you with two lines
just like we've been looking at before
in some ways that's exactly like
question one no big deal so you can go
ahead with that in a second question
three no it's a bit differently
different can you have a look at it with
me it says solve each equation
graphically now when we say graphic and
what we mean is like this with the aid
of graphics by graphing them and you can
see what the solutions are and then read
what it is okay
the weird thing is if you have a look
closely at question three the parts look
very different from what we've got
there's no y equals this there's no y
equals that you've just got X's here's
what they mean open your lids up again
and instead of the two equations you had
before replace them with the left hand
side and the right hand side of those
two equations or the one equation you
can say in question three so for example
in fact I can even get rid of the y
equals in the top line I'm just going to
write the left hand side of the equation
in 3a which says 2x is it 2x minus one
now when you put in 2 X minus 1 by
itself desmos is guessing that you mean
y equals this and that's why you can see
a graph right this is the 2x minus 1
part of the graph then we can put on the
line beneath the right hand side of the
equation it's X plus 2 X plus 2 now you
may need to ask just like I do
you may need to move the part of your
graph that is visible so you can see the
point of intersection you might need to
zoom out as well
eventually you'll see can you help me
whoops can you help me read off what the
solution is for this what's the what's
the coordinates where's the point of
intersection 3 3 comma 5 right so I can
write that down 3 comma 5 but I want to
ask you guys which number is which which
one's the X term which one's the Y this
is the X right this is the Y now look
back at the original question do you
notice it doesn't have any Y Z that's
what I was highlighting so which of
these numbers do I really care about
[Music]
look at the question it's a question
that's all about what pruning rule it's
all of that X right so therefore I use
this and I say the part that I'm
focusing on is the X now question 4
underneath asks you to confirm this just
by doing it with algebra which we can do
right now pick up your pen these
equation this equation was 2x what was
it minus 1 equals x plus 2 so right ok
now if we didn't have a graph we could
just solve this as an equation we could
probably take 2 steps what could be
something we do to both sides to make
this simpler anyway what do you see
we switch the minus 1 and the X so I'm
guessing what you mean is how do we
switch by the way like I don't want this
minus one to be here what do I do to
both sides to get rid of it hmm that's
interesting I actually could multiply by
minus 1 but it would just turn it into a
plus 1 so it's sort of still be there
the rest of you said we could add 1
that'll get rid of this here which would
make this not plus 2 when you add 1 to
both sides it'll become plus 3 and then
I need one more step what was the other
thing I need to do Anoosh ah - 2 now I
have it to here but actually this is
kind of a different operation hiding
there right what's the operation that's
hiding it's multiplication what's the
thing I use to undo that division right
so I should divide this or if I divide
both sides by 2 I would get more X's
over here I think we could subtract X
right so I'm going to subtract X from
here and then I'm going to subtract X
from here what do we get which is what
we confirmed earlier ok